Garcia, stiffly: ANOTHER HOT
DATE TONIGHT, BILL?
Junior: AND HOW. AND SHE'S A
REAL CATCH, TOO--INTELLIGENT,
CHALLENGING, AND SHE'S 16
YEARS OLD, THE LEGAL AGE OF
CONSENT IN THE STATE OF NEVADA.
WE'RE GOIN' DINNER--FOR DINNER,
ROLLER-SKATING. THEN WE MIGHT
POP OVER TO CALIFORNIA FOR SOME
DANCING.
Garcia: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA. SLOW
DOWN, BILL.
Junior: WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
Garcia: WELL, 16 MAY BE THE AGE
OF CONSENT IN NEVADA, BUT NOT IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S 18 IN THE
GOLDEN STATE.
Junior: HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO
KEEP TRACK?
Garcia: WHY NOT DO WHAT I DO?
I ALWAYS CARRY AGE OF CONSENT
STATE-BY-STATE GUIDE.
Junior: 14 IN IDAHO? HOW DID I
EVER LIVE WITHOUT ONE OF THESE
HANDY CARDS?
Garcia: ORDER YOURS TODAY. WHY
NOT BE SURE EVERY TIME?